من هنا في منطقه الرادوم بولايه جنوب
دارفور تبدا الحرب على المخدرات
الرادوم التي باتت تعرفاء بكولومبيا
السودان اشتهرت بزراعه النبات القنب
الهندي لذلك تقوم قوات مكافحه المخدرات
اتلاف للبانجو وحرقه في موسم الحصاد لمنع
تسرب السمومه الى الناس
لكن ذلك لم يمنع وقوع شبان كثيرين في
براثن الادمان كينجي وهو اسم مستعار احد
هؤلاء لم يدرك حينها انه يلقي بنفسه الى
التهلكه والله
[موسيقى]
بحاول اعمل
فقدت الاصدقاء وفقدت
انا جربتها لكن تمت مؤشر اخر يبعث على
القلق اذ وجدت هذه السموم سبيلها الى
الصغار ايضا اقل طفل جانب المركز قادرين
عمره عشر سنوات الان نحن في قسم البنات
اقل عمر للبنات 13 سنه يبقى المخدرات ما
هي اصبحت الشيء بتهدد الشباب اللي فوق
كبير حتى الاطفال للمخدرات هي اسماء
متعدده لكن ما باتا يؤرق من السودانيين هو
ما يعرف بمخدر الايس او الكريستال ميثم
خطوره بسبب ضمور في خلايا المخ بعد
التعاطي لفترات طويله زي ما شايفين في
الصورتين الفرق ما بين خلايا المخ
الطبيعيه وخلايا مخ حاصل لها ضمور بعد
طاعات الايس لفترات طويله تركز انتشار
مخدر الايس بحسب اداره مكافحه المخدرات في
الولايات الشرقيه المطله على البحر الاحمر
ثم في ولايه وسط السودان وفي الشمال
بمحاذاه نهر النيل الى الولايات الشماليه
وتحول السودان الى دوله عبور للمخدرات الى
دول اخرى مهدي السلطات الى مواصفاته
بالتهديد للامن القومي بعد تفكيك شبكات
محليه لتصنيع المخدرات وهذا مؤشر خطير
ينوم معنا ان هنالك من يفكر في التصنيع
الحبوب التي كانت تاتي الينا مهربه
عبر الحدود
تسعى هذه القوه المشتركه الى مكافحه
المخدرات والحد من انتشارها خاصه بعد ان
ظهرت الاحصاءات زياده ملحوظه خلال الاعوام
الاخيره في كميه المخدرات التي تدخل
البلاد واعداد المتعاطين والجرائم
المرتبطه بهم الطاهر المرضي الجزيره
الخرطوم